alors maintenant merengues en bas de
chez vous allez être soumis à une
interview un petit peu spécial ça
s'appelle lardy view et on ne bouge pas
par le jingle on n'accouche pas pendant
le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous pensez à quoi la rochelle contact
je pense que le contact a été bon vous
avez raison
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois
bréchet sera ici un enterrement de ma
femme
vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
bonjour il ya brillé une fois ce projet
je ne l'aurais pas utiliser cette
baguette magique
copwatch taurine damas était moribond
comment si vous voulez aider quelqu'un
ne faut pas lui donner du poisson il
faut les apprendre comment pêcher
[Applaudissements]
si notre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi dans cette vie
donc je suis naïve à yabuli mignan eh
bien je n'aurais peut-être pas changer
ma vie car en fait je suis content de
mon surf isbn extrait you moi je viens
d'une famille pauvre desprès gessien
province alors je viens d'un pays
province profonde et je suis monté au
sommet quand même quelque chose
contre si j'avais à refaire la paire
historique un
tir je leur ai fait le même choix
j'arrête toujours choisi la liberté la
démocratie la snes l'ouverture
demain j'aurais changé quelque peu mes
priorités
ça c'est sûr je reconnais mes erreurs et
je pense que la pérestroïka aurait
continué à ce moment là imaginons que l
époque au début du siècle dernier le
tsar nicolas ii n'ait pas été renversées
et que la russie se soient modernisés
mais en restant dans le monde occidental
est et sous le régime du tsar peut-être
une façon plus constitutionnel est ce
qu'aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle en
2001 est-ce que vous pensez que la
russie serait plus en avance ou moins en
avance est-ce que vous pensez que la
révolution soviétique a fait progresser
globalement globalement positif comme
disait georges marchais et fils
responsable du parti communiste français
est ce que pensait que l'expérience a
été globalement positive ou globalement
négative
des dégâts
sérieux
ça me fait penser une histoire il ya une
délégation français au prix bien en
visite officielle en chine
ils sont accueillis par twin l'eau et
les vias et lui pose la question
suivante
que pensez-vous de l'aviron sera de la
révolution française sur le monde et sur
la chine deviendra y 4 rona est bien le
premier ministre chinois de l'époque
a répondu ceci
étant dit il est encore trop tôt pour
tirer de conclusions définitives moitié
en bois la pierre puisque les mondiaux
c'est sur leur apprendre comment vivez
vous faire le bilan de la révolution
d'octobre
comment aimeriez-vous mourir
on ne reviendra c'est dieu qui décidera
est ce que vous croyez en dieu
merci beaucoup et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu